[Music]
you know who's not smiling probably
today
Megan Markel new drama for the royal
newlyweds today
yeah Megan's father Thomas Merkel is
speaking out once again meanwhile the
Duke and Duchess in her new royal role
join the Queen today I can't wait to see
all you'll do to change the world
Duchess Megan sat in the front row with
Harry's grandmother as Harry spoke at
the Queen's young leader Awards Megan
wore her hair down donning a belted pale
pink Prada dress with a double row
buttons Her Majesty recently appointed
Harry to be a Commonwealth Youth
Ambassador I together with my wife Megan
look forward to hear your ideas David
Beckham also attended the Buckingham
Palace event sharing a moment with the
Queen but behind Megan's public smiles
there's more family drama brewing her
father Thomas Markel now says he's
getting the royal cold shoulder ever
since he did that controversial paid TV
interview with good morning Britain
Harry asked for her hand over the phone
and I said you're a gentleman promise me
you'll never raise your hand against my
daughter and of course I give you my
information today Merkel tells TMZ that
he hasn't spoken to Megan since that
appearance nor has he talked to anyone
else from the palace
he still hasn't met his son-in-law in
person but he is hopeful he will make a
trip overseas soon and also wants to
meet the Queen another royal news
oscar-winner Susan Sarandon made a royal
faux pas over the weekend while the
Queen and Prince Philip were watching a
polo match the actress step right up and
introduced herself now not only is that
against protocol but Serena's short
skirt caused a stir
[Music]